so did anything else notable happen to
you at the convention
oh i don't know
did anything i mean i'd i got to see a
lot of people i haven't seen in years
which was did you did you guys get
recognized anywhere like at a weird
place that like was not in the
convention oh i i i got oh because uh
the hotel they put us in was like
literally like the con hotel yeah so
like anyone was going to the con was
staying in this hotel yeah
and like i'm in the elevator sorry lyft
um
and uh i wow you've changed
i've changed so i come on the lift right
and uh there's this guy and he's like oh
wow you'll see dog right and i'm like
yeah yeah what's up he's like yo can i
have a picture i'm like yeah sure let's
do it let's do it
so like i'm taking a picture with this
guy and he's like he's trying to get his
phone ready and he's like giving stuff
to his girlfriend or whoever this is
yeah and this girlfriend's like
who is this guy yeah and he's like yo
it's sea dog and she's like all right
and he's like yeah you should i used to
watch his videos
bruh that's a that's a brawl that's a
problem
and i like he said this to her and
looked at me and just smiled like really
the picture and i'm like
like [ __ ] like unravel starts playing
i used to watch his pictures i was like
i was like i was like what the [ __ ] dude
like
like oh you're just like what happened
yeah i get it maybe you get
right busy right but you could say that
a little later wait what are you gonna
say to my face
that's kind of like let's kind of scare
like l plus ratio fell off like
yeah this guy was like i used to watch
his videos and i mean he like just
smiled at me and i was like i was like
what
brother
used to
well i mean i guess like one notable
thing was uh the panel that we had on
sunday
oh yeah how did that go because i wasn't
there yeah so it was kind of like so the
saturday panel was kind of like a q and
a type of thing right yeah i was like
there was a microphone in the crowd
people could come up and ask the
questions you'd answer type of thing uh
but the sunday one it was like the title
of it was a conversation with the anime
manager va yeah so we structured it kind
of like it was me and connor on the
stage and then we kind of had like an
emcee type of thing who was there to
navigate and ask like general questions
like get a flow of conversation going
right and uh because we asked this mc
guy who was a great mc mind you but it
was very last minute right yeah he
obviously didn't know who me and connor
were what we do right like he only knew
like a very baseline information yeah so
uh you know obviously the a lot of the
questions were like very general
but
then that was one question
it was like uh
something along the lines of like yeah
so uh i i was uh an emceeing for uh
your wife sid snap
and he was like and he was like and he
was like looking straight at me
and i was like
uh
and i looked at conor and uh you know we
kind of like met eyes and i looked back
at the emcee i was like
could you repeat
i was like yeah yeah you're your fiance
and wife uh a sydney or sid snap yeah
she
she was telling me all these stories
about how you know the you know planning
for the wedding and all that kind of
stuff and i was like
and you know there was a murmur
happening in the crowd and i was like um
and i just like slowly pulled my hand
out and i was like i'm joey by the way
it's like no no you're
you're grant or god right
and i was like is this really happening
is accidental racism happening live on
stage right now and uh and i think
people in the crowd are kind of like aha
yeah funny bit yeah yeah yeah good nice
nice nice execution nice landing guys
like meanwhile i'm just like
this [ __ ] literally confused me
with a gun like what all asians look the
same now that how it is congratulations
on getting married to sydney by the way
thank you thank you yeah
hope the winning goes well
you know i've been planning it for a
while now you know how it is
oh and i think uh alan said at best uh
last night he was like wow i can't
believe he confused the anime zone with
the anime man
easy mistake
when you put it that way fair enough i
don't know none of you are watching
anime
i could sympathize with him you know he
kind of got dragged to do it last minute
and i and i could tell when like and he
was like trying to double down on him
that was the thing that i was like no no
come on baby he was like no i'm sure it
was something something i'm like
just just move on and then and then
there was a moment during the panel
where like people in the crowd started
to laugh when he doubled down and just
like wouldn't land and he just like put
both his hands in his face and he was
just like oh no i've made a horrible
mistake and i was like don't
it was funny and harmless and you know
great great story for the podcast i was
like it's whatever yeah but other than
that yeah why are you gone
you are gone
i am not god you are god
one funny thing that happened actually
was uh
so you know i got recognized by someone
i got you know took a picture with them
and they were like
you're not gonna believe this i saw the
most convincing sydney look-alike i've
ever seen in my life okay i'm like oh
okay let's let let me see this
what's like i i want to see if there's a
my wife look alike yeah yeah
you like slightly like gets out of his
phone like puts puts the picture on
starts swiping like furiously and he
goes look at that
does that not look like sydney and it's
him
standing next to sydney
and i'm just like
my god i think that's just sydney and
he's like no no let me show you another
picture so she he shows me a full body
shot of sydney
and i'm like
no
i think i think you are just got a
picture of sydney i want to know what
sydney looks like in this guy's head
like the real sydney what he looks like
in this guy's hand how did so how did he
take a picture of sydney and like
explain it to her no because because
what he explained to me was no you you
don't understand like i asked her if she
was sid snap and she said no
what
why
because sydney being the troll that she
is sometimes she's like are you sendish
like now
so this guy's like can we take a picture
just so you know i i just gotta get i
just get i just got it you look so much
like sydney i just need to take a
picture so sydney tell me this can be
inspired
it's like well i guess she's not there
she's like so what he was saying was
like he's told me yeah she looked like
sydney yeah and she sounded like sydney
but she told me she wasn't sydney so
there's a so this this british dude
thought there was an american sydney
look alike
in london i think he thought she must
have been cosplaying sydney
like that's a wig right that's what
you're really
saying it's your girl probably should be
like committed to like hard
i remember because like i was with a
friend and i was like because we were
outside a hotel and i was just like
because he like refused to believe me
that he was like sydney so i'm like can
you like i turn to my friend like can
you go get sydney please and he's just
like he was just like so like shell
shock like it was like speech a hundred
you know sydney was just like cindy had
like convinced him that she just was not
sydney by saying one line that i am not
sid snap and then like so my friend gets
sydney and the first thing he she says
is you stupid [ __ ]
japanese debated
i love how all it took for sydney to get
away from that situation was her just
saying no meanwhile this guy's in a full
[ __ ] like
disguise and he can't get away with it
at all maybe i should have just you know
just been like are you see you're always
like nah nah i'm not like oh well [ __ ] i
guess it's not yeah yeah oh i love your
videos who yeah who who was you
did it again what the [ __ ] well i mean
to be fair you you weren't sea dog that
weekend you were sea dogs
one of my favorite pictures of that
entire weekend was just
your your like face of just confusion in
front of your picture it wasn't even
like me pulling i was just walking yeah
he was literally just walking and i just
like took a candid shot i've kind of
just been like
in front of the side that said see dogs
v8 because it just looked like
your face just looked like you were just
you had just like gone through like like
you're like the end of the universe you
want to explain what's happening because
okay
okay so at the signing right we had like
a dedicated section for our signing you
know there was a picture of all three of
us that said trash taste and then there
was individual photos of like yeah man
man gig and then next to that there was
a picture of connor
but it's instead of saying c dog va it
said see dogs with a z
v-a
and i i remember i i like you know i was
admiring you know the posters being like
oh yeah you know we look sick in these
and then i did a double take with
connor's like
see what he said
i don't know i see dogs
me neither and i was just like i was
just like you should change your name to
see dogs va it looks so sick
it was that and they were coming the
next day and it's just like like black
that would mark and i laughed even
it was the most like inconspicuous
i just kind of felt like i was like i
don't care
everyone kept coming out to me like wow
you must be so offended i'm like why
would i give a [ __ ] yeah i mean i've had
that happen before yeah i was just like
i don't really care it's not like it i'm
suddenly now like a different person
it's like a file location where if you
type in the wrong thing yeah it's like
dot c-dog dot exe is missing it's like
i'm still here like at least like at
least you know the large majority of
your name was still there and intact
like i've had i've been to a convention
where they had a sign up and it said the
anime guy yeah so i'm just like i'm like
that's just a completely different
person
they must have
no no they weren't they were genuine
they genuinely thought i was the anime
guy and i was and i didn't have the
heart to tell them yes at the time
another timeline i was just like all
right you know what i'm it's good enough
[ __ ] it yeah for me like every
convention i go to it's like a 50 50
chance of whether it'd be gigguk or gig
uk that is that is like i swear half the
conventions i go to is just gig uk
unfortunately i guess i guess it's
helpful for having amazing if you're in
london it should have been gig uk yeah
that makes sense right yeah it's uh when
we go to like australia it'll be
a us
or just geek us in like us
in america
but yeah like another thing like i
noticed is just like
every time you like hang out with your
mates or with somewhere where you think
you're private it's just like if if
someone mentions that wouldn't this be a
funny time for you to get noticed it is
like the worst [ __ ] it is it is all
it's like summoning the devil you know
it is going to happen so that because
that happened to me uh well it happened
to me indirectly right because so we
were outside a hotel and we were just
i was chilling out there was pretty late
at night it was about 1am uh and we see
this guy just stumble over to like the
tree
and he just starts throwing up right and
he and we're just like [ __ ] who is uh is
is he all right he's uh he's obviously
not in the right state of mind i don't
know where his mates are um so we go
over to him and he's obviously had too
many drinks uh that night yeah uh and
unfortunately he didn't know where his
mates were which if you're watching this
guy if you're watching this and you uh
happen to be a trash taste watcher get
better mates
you don't leave your mates down you
don't leave your mates out like that
exactly
that's quite [ __ ] up yeah yeah yeah
yeah so it's by the tree uh luckily you
know luckily some some some guys uh some
like a father had uh had found him and
was trying to make sure that he was okay
and so we went over and started to help
out as well just to make sure that he
was kosher and everything uh making sure
that uh he was all right he was all
right he's gonna get home uh so we
managed to contact his sister
and keep in mind it's like one
1 a.m 2 a.m you know like he's just out
here in the middle of london and she was
like i believe like on the other side of
london or something and we were just
like
can you come pick your brother up and uh
you know being being the giga chad
sister that she was she's like yeah yeah
just tell me where she is let me get
there now i'll i'll come bring him home
right so we were with him for like a
good like you know half hour to 45
minutes making sure he was okay making
sure he was warm you know make sure he
wasn't too passed out um and just
being hopefully being a good samaritan
while waiting for this waiting for this
mythical sister to come being a good
replacement for the [ __ ] mates yeah yeah
yeah yeah that's right right right
um and so we're with him for half an
hour of 245 minutes and then i go i go
into the toilet
uh
quickly and then as i come outside
apparently when i was in the toilet this
mythical sister comes right and she's
just like oh thank you so much for
taking care of my brother i'm so sorry
you know i don't know what's happened to
his mates i don't know what's happened
to him um i'll make sure he gets home
okay and then like the next line which
is the line i heard as i was walking out
uh to uh as i was walking out the door
to go outside again was by the way did
you guys see the trash chase boys in mcm
today
the sister said that yeah yeah yeah the
sisters said this right it was like my
mates told me it was like sitcom level
timing right she was like so
compassionate and then she was just
trying to make conversation yeah and
then she she she just mentioned have you
did you guys manage to see the trash
table
slowly back inside no no and then like
the the automatic doors open and then
everyone looks at me and she just goes
no
no
you wait you're on the phone with her
all right no i was i wasn't on the phone
but i i mean uh i wasn't on the phone
with her it was uh someone else on the
phone but right they had mentioned that
you know we had a bunch of guys taking
care um of her brother and i i was like
the guy who was just like chatting to
him trying to get trying to make sure
trying to know what the [ __ ] happened to
him tonight and make sure he felt
comfortable with that [ __ ] and he's just
like
you were taking care of him you you yeah
and i'm just like are you the sister are
you the mythical sister yeah i'm just
like yes
and i was like i was like first i said
go thank you so much for being [ __ ]
amazing and she's like
i could tell like she was like trying to
hold in her excitement and then and then
she like she pauses for a second she
looks at her brother dead on the floor
and she's like
i know this is a bad time
but is it cool if i ask for a picture
no no
no and i'm just like doesn't even sound
real dude i know i 100 it happened and
i'm just like look you were like such a
[ __ ] giga chad for coming all the way
out here like 1am uh you know luckily we
had other people to take care of her
brother just like we take a quick
picture she goes home and uh everyone's
safe everyone's please tell me the
brother was in the shot like in the
background like like it's like that mean
picture of the guy like leaning towards
the grave and like doing that
except it's like the brotherhood is just
like dead on the floor like
it doesn't even sound real like it
sounds so like like in between his eyes
it was like so surreal
one of the funniest things that happened
to me that weekend um but yes it's just
like sometimes you just have like really
weird coincidences and weird timings
with [ __ ] man that is that is like the
words you must never utter at a con yeah
of like huh what if hilarious right and
then almost every single time it's like
oh
from a distance you know right right
where's the candle yeah yeah yeah
where's
where's the live audience yeah